تداولت وسائل اعلام بلجيكيه قصه بطوليه
لشاب جزائري يدعى ندير انقض امراه من
الغرق في نهر في بلجيكا وذكرت الصحف
البلجيكيه ان نذير راى سيده تسقط في النهر
ليسارع في انقاذها وابقائها على قيد
الحياه لحين وصول رجال الانقاذ اليها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو يظهر شبان يلعبون كره القدم في نهر
دجله بالعراق واظهر الفيديو مساحات فارغه
مقاع النهر اثرى انخفاض حاد منسوب المياه
غير مسبوق المشهد اثار غضب واستياء رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
العراقيين حاليا لعبه طوبه داخل
من جهه الاعظميه والمقابله الجهه المقابله
الكاظميه على جسر الائمه
وهذول الشباب يلعبون
طابه داخل هذا النهر
عليهم
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور اكثر من قرن على غرق سفينه
التايتنك لا تزال هناك كنوز جديده يتم
اكتشاف اكتشافها في موقع الحطب حيث التقطت
شركه رسم الخرائط في المملكه المتحده صورا
لمجوهرات ذهبيه عثر عليها في مسح رقمي
ويقول مسؤول الشركه انهم سيحاولون التعرف
على المالك من صور الركاب الذين كانوا على
متنها وعددهم 21 عندما غرقت السفينه عام
1912 وسيتم تحليل لقطات للركاب خاصه
وجوههم وملابسهم كجزء من المشروع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد ان انتشرت قصته بشكل كبير في انحاء
الجزائر واحزن رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بشكل كبير الشعب الجزائري
اسماعيل برابح يبدا رحله علاجه في تخطي
حزنه على وفاه والدته التي كان ينام كان
ينام بجوار قبرها لمده عامين الشاب اثار
استعطاف الكثيرين وبعد تداول قصته تحركت
السلطات في الجزائر وكلفت فريقا طبيا
لعلاجه نفسيا وعقليا والعنايه به
الله المستعان
[موسيقى]
والله المستعان والله المستعان الله
المستعان
كان هذا كل
شيء لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات